nos dicen que fx es igual a esta serie
infinita y tenemos que encontrar la
tercera derivada evaluada cuando x es
igual a 0 y como siempre los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta antes de que
lo resolvamos juntos hay dos formas de
resolver esto una es simplemente tomar
la derivada de esta expresión que
tenemos en notación sigma y otra forma
de hacerlo es expandir fx y realizar
tres veces su derivada para obtener una
respuesta que quizás tenga sentido
primero realicemos la segunda forma
vamos a expandirla fx es igual veamos
cuando n es igual a 0 esto es igual a
menos 1 a la 0 es 1 por x a la 2 por 0 3
pues va a ser cero más 3 pues x a la 3
entre dos veces 0 +1 factorial así que
va a ser entre 1 el siguiente terminó
cuando n es igual a 1 tendremos menos
a la 1 así que esto no va a ser sumada a
ser resta de x a la 2 por n 2 x 1 35 x a
la quinta entre 2 por n que es 12 por
uno más uno es 33 factorial 3 factorial
es 6 así que es x a la quinta en 36
cuando n es igual a 2 aquí tendremos
menos 1 al cuadrado va a ser positivo x
a la 2 por n por dos enes 22 por 243 es
7x a la 7 entre 2 por nn es 2 2 por 2 4
155 factorial y vamos a escribirlo así 5
factoriales sería 5 por 4 por 6 pero
vamos a dejarlo así el siguiente será
negativo el siguiente será positivo y
así sucesivamente
ahora realicemos la derivada de esto efe
prima de x va a ser igual aplicamos la
regla de la potencia y bajamos el
exponente 3
x al cuadrado menos 5 sextos por equis a
la cuarta más 7 entre 5 factorial por
equis a las 6 menos más y así por
siempre calculamos la segunda derivada f
prima prima de x es igual de nuevo
aplicamos la regla de la potencia es
igual a 6 por x a la 1 menos 5 sextos
por 4 es 20 entre 6 x al cubo más 6 por
7 42 entre 5 factorial por x a la quinta
menos más y así hasta el infinito
alternamos entre algo negativo y algo
positivo y así hasta el infinito y ahora
hacemos la tercera derivada f prima
prima prima de x es igual la derivada de
6 x 6 menos 20 por 360 entre 6 bueno sé
que va a ser igual a 10 pero lo dejamos
así menos 60 entre 6 por x al cuadrado
42 por 53 210 entre 5 factorial por
equis a la cuarta menos algo más algo y
así hasta el infinito y ahora vamos a
evaluar esto cuando x es igual a 0 todos
estos términos que están multiplicados
por x se van a volver 0 y solo nos vamos
a quedar con este 6 de aquí así que esto
es igual a 6 así que la tercera derivada
de f evaluada en 0 es igual a 6 otra
forma en la que pudimos resolver esto es
mantener la notación sigma y encontrar
la tercera derivada de esto
la primera derivada de x es igual a la
suma desde que en es igual a cero hasta
infinito de la derivada de esto la
derivada es con respecto a x así que
para este propósito suponemos que todo
lo que no tiene x es una constante en él
solo nos va a decir cómo cambiamos de
término a término así que tomamos la
derivada con respecto a x usamos la
regla de la potencia bajamos el
exponente y ponemos menos 1 a la n por 2
n 3 que multiplica a x con este
exponente de cree mentado en 12 n 2
dividido entre 2 n 1 factorial tomamos
la segunda derivada f prima prima de x
es igual a la suma desde que en es igual
a cero hasta infinito de menos 1 a la n
por 2 n 3
por ahora tomamos este exponente y lo
bajamos 2 n
todo esto dividido entre 2 n 1 factorial
y esto estará x x a la 2 n más uno
parece que lo que hago es complicado
pero realmente lo que hago en cada
ocasión es tomar el exponente bajarlo
multiplicarlo por esto y de incrementar
el exponente de aquí en 1 y para la
tercera derivada f prima prima prima de
x es igual la suma desde cero hasta
infinito de menos 1 a la n iv tenemos 2
n 3 x 12 n 2 x 2 n 1 todo esto entre 2 n
1 factorial y esto está x x a la 2 por n
ahora vamos a evaluar esto para x igual
a 0 es igual
a la suma desde que n es igual a cero
hasta infinito de y esto está
interesante tenemos todo esto 2 n 3 por
2 n 2 por 2 n 1 / 2 n más 1 factorial x
0 a la 2 por m y quizás se vean tentados
a decir oye pues todo esto está x 0 así
que va a ser igual a 0 pero recuerden
que comenzamos desde n igual a 0
así que para cualquier n que no sea
igual a 0
este 0 a esta potencia va a ser igual a
0 y estos términos van a desaparecer así
que el único término que importa aquí es
cuando n es igual a 0 porque tenemos
este 0 elevado a la 0 ya que cualquier
cosa elevada a la 0 va a ser igual a 1
así que cuando n es igual a cero
tendremos menos 10
qué es 11 por esto es 3 por 2 por 1
entre 1 factorial x 0 a la 0 que es
igual a 1 por lo que todo esto es igual
a 6 así que tenemos el mismo resultado
en ambas formas el primer método me
parece que es un poco más directo y un
poco más intuitivo parecido a cosas que
ya han visto antes pero vean que hicimos
lo mismo con ambos métodos solo que aquí
lo mantuvimos con la anotación sigma y
esta técnica es útil porque en muchas
ocasiones se van a encontrar que
necesitan resolver las cosas de una
manera más general por lo que quizás sea
útil realizar las derivadas mientras
tenemos la expresión en notación sigma